We will now dive into some of the specifics of how D3 works, and
why it is becoming the go to tool for anyone who wants to visualize data.
Rather than obscure and hide the Document Object Model,
D3 embraces it by directly manipulating HTML modes and
SVG objects, Through common conventions like CSS selectors.
By doing so, D3 has enabled much more expressive visualizations and
allows designers to directly interact with developers,
by separating the style of a visualization from the mechanics of it.
D3 visualizations, Since they operate directly on HTML through the DOM and SVG,
can be styled in the exact same way as any other web page, such as with CSS.
And D3 code can actually manipulate already created and HTML documents.
We will see an example of this when we get to the live code portion of
this lesson and actually manipulate this very web page and
change some of the stylings and elements.
One example of leveraging this power might be to pre-render HTML and SVG objects
for a complex visualization on the server side, and then simply use JavaScript
for any sort of interaction or dynamics that we need on the client side.
If you have the libraries built on top of D3, actually do exactly this and
allow you to render on the server side D3 objects to static images or JSON.
The last benefit I will mention, though there are quite a few more, is that,
since D3 visualizations operate on the DOM and HTML directly, they can leverage
all the improvements and advances of the open web, such as browser enhancements,
JavaScript speed increases, and newer standards, such as HTML5.
And also, developers can use all of their familiar tools to work with D3.
Such as debuggers, text editors, existing libraries.